au fur et à mesure que les heures
passent
le bilan du tremblement de terre du
guatemala bros on parle ce matin de
20000 morts et de plus de 50 mille
blessés mais les chiffres officiels font
toujours état de treize mille victimes
en effet tant que les recherches dans
les décombres ne sont pas terminées il
est impossible de dresser un bilan
définitif de ce séisme qui a détruit à
moitié le pays alain rodier
chimaltenango a vécu sur les vingt mille
habitants de cette localité douce ont
été tuées trois mille blessés et le
geste de cette vieille femme implorant
au milieu des décombres
cherchant un peu de pitié dans les yeux
d'une statue montre à quel point le
désespoir de la population est profond
aujourd'hui le fin fond de l'horreur et
at il y à des villes dont on ignore
encore le sort et sauveteurs sont
débordés tout manque l'eau le pain les
médicaments les médecins et tandis que
la terre continue à trembler des
milliers de guatémaltèques en province
continuent d'attendre l'arrivée des
secours depuis mercredi il ya eu 500
secousses la dernière en date la plus
violente s'est fait ressentir hier vers
midi on estime maintenant le nombre des
morts à 15000 mais certains n'ont pas
hésité en annonces et 20000 il y aurait
cinq cent mille blessés deux cent mille
sans abri 60% des immeubles ne sont plus
que ruines et en face de cela on le
trouve qu'une poignée d'hommes
huit mille cadavres seulement ont été
inhumés pour l'instant et maintenant les
sauveteurs réclament des lance-flammes
pour brûler les cadavres
les premières manifestations de la
typhoïde sont apparus et l'on parle déjà
de la peste mais en attendant les
bronchites se développe la nuit la
température a baissé jusqu'à moins 12
derrière sous les décombres mourir de
froid ou de maladie c'est pour l'instant
le seul choix pour la majorité de la
population
dans quelques instants nous
recueillerons le témoignage d'une
française qui était présente lorsque les
premières secousses se sont fait sentir
au guatemala madame moreau neyret mais
auparavant michel chevalet et vient de
retenir le chiffre de 500 secousses
alain rodier vient de nous le dire 500
secousses des secousses extrêmement
importante alors tout ça n'était il pas
prévisible
est ce que tout cela va continuer cent
ans puisse rien faire
continuez je crois que ça risque de
continuer je pas oublier ça va s'arrêter
où ça continuera on ne peut pas le dire
dans l'état actuel des connaissances des
géophysiciens ensuite ce qui est
surprenant
si vous voulez yves rausis et l'ampleur
tout de même phénomène généralement un
tremblement de terre les secousses dure
quelques dizaines de secondes y en a
deux trois puis après la terre se rtas
en quelque sorte se réajuste et puis
cela cesse en fait ce qui surprend ici
c'est bien l'ampleur et ça laisse
supposer que malheureusement cette
région du globe va connaître dans les
années à venir d'un nouveau tremblement
de terre en fait ce qu'il faut voir dans
cette tragique affaire du guatemala
c'est que le les tremblements de terre
là vous voyez la carte mais on va y
revenir c'est que ça tient en une seule
phrase c'est la dérive des continents
en fait c'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau monsieur wegener un autrichien
avait remarqué notamment que l'amérique
du sud et l'afrique s'emboîtaient à la
perfection et c'est valable encore pour
d'autres régions du globe ans qui lui
manquait c'était le moteur qui a mis en
route les continents et ce moteur bien
des américains l'ont trouvé il ya dix
ans ils l'ont trouvée non pas sur terre
mais au milieu là d'anti grâce à un
bateau qui effectue des forages bloemers
challenger et à l'issue de cette
campagne de forage
on a mis en évidence qu'au milieu de
l'atlantique il y avait une gigantesque
faille que vous voyez comment une faille
qui part du pôle nord jusqu'au sud et à
la suite de l'analyse des roches
vous avez reçue que les deux lèvres de
cette faille s'écartait comme de tapis
roulant c'est de la lave qui monte du
fonds à 100 200 kilomètres d'épaisseur
et de fait l'europe et l'amérique
s'éloigne toujours à raison de deux à
trois centimètres par an ce qui est
colossal pour le globe bien entendu et
regardez ce document voici ce qui s'est
passé il ya 200 millions de
mais vous voyez qu'un seul continent
s'est fractionné et la terre c'est en
quelque sorte façonné en vous le repasse
une deuxième fois
voici un seul continent et puis d'un
seul coup il ya 200 millions d'années
space 2 débarque par exemple l'inde où
il est l'âne qui était au pôle sud
remontent et va se planter dans le dans
l'asie et de ce choc est née l'himalaya
voilà donc un peu l'histoire de la
dérive des continents une histoire
fabuleuse mais qui continue actuellement
et jean claude delannoy vous montrer la
carte de cette région du globe et sur
cette carte vous voyez tout à fait à
droite une ligne verticale c'est la
faille au milieu de l'atlantique
ensuite vous voyez le long du continent
américain avait à côté du cercle de
guatemala la grande faille une deuxième
grande faille les flèches vous indique
le mouvement de ces plaques or
malheureusement regardez bien le
guatemala se trouve à l'intersection de
quatre plaques en quelque sorte la
plaque qui est complètement à gauche
celle qui porte pacifique veut passer
sous le continent américain en fait de
continent américain la flèche tout le
monde remonte vers le nord est
actuellement est bien le guatemala en
train de vivre un épisode de la
formation de la terre et morosi c'est à
dire qu'au guatemala
d'une part il ya écrasement du continent
américain et d'autre part ouverture
c'est à dire en quelque sorte le canal
de suez et de cazals parlons de panama
est en train de s'ouvrir
oui ou c'est eu un épisode de la
formation du globe si vous voulez nous à
notre échelle d'homme on ne se rend pas
compte d'un meilleur dans se façonnent
nos globes
or malheureusement les habitants du
guatemala sont en train de le vivre
comme l'a vécu madame
[Musique]